and he's ready magnus carlson ready for
the final in the ftx crypto cup
congratulations minus
thank you so well today i mean
going back to game one how determined
were you to
really put rajabov in some well
uncomfortable situations from the get-go
i cannot say that i had a
very aggressive mindset but i decided at
least i wanted to
play something less theoretical and try
and get a game but
i mean realistically i think i messed
something up and i was just
quite a bit worse uh but fortunately
um yeah i managed to solve my my
problems
um you probably didn't choose the right
way
and um after that i already felt like i
had some psychological
initiatives i tried to fire find a way
to
to play for a win and yeah finally
um finally he um he um
he blundered which was very very
satisfying because it was easy
at some point in that game to be
satisfied with the fact that i
solved my problems and that i could make
a draw but
i was always trying to keep keep some
life and
it really paid off magnus ending on a
loss yesterday how
how difficult was it to recover from
that do you think game one today was the
turning point in the match overall
oh yeah for sure um obviously
it wasn't was an idea um
what happened in the last game yesterday
but
i knew
yeah i knew that uh it's
sort of easier i feel to
uh to adjust this time than it was in
their preliminaries
uh because this time it's
it's still sort of more in my own hands
that i i just have one
one opponent to to beat once so it was
obviously very upsetting but
nevertheless i i think i dealt with it
definitely fine and i had
definitely had a decent mindset coming
into today
and well it's been a tense tournament so
far uh with the preliminaries that final
day
the quad final against ikaru and now
against timor ajabo decided today how
are you feeling about
the way you're playing minus no
see as you said yeah it's been it's been
awfully
it's been awfully tense um i can't say
that my play is like
flowing great but
i mean i'm in the finals and that's
that's the most important thing so you
can always
you can always yeah i improve as you as
you get there but
as as i've said before as well i think i
need to play better to
to beat wesley um that than i have so
far but
um the way the tournament has been going
like even being in the final is uh
obviously a massive uh achievement for
me yeah
and now as you mentioned wesley so in
the third final for you so far
in the tour uh what will you do
differently to beat him this time
well i did beat him in the one third
place yeah that's great
um i don't really know to to be honest
he's
he's not an easy easy person to beat
i think he was pretty vulnerable
yesterday
and as much but today seemed a lot more
convincing so
he's very strong
yeah it's gonna be an interesting final
magnus what's uh
what will you do uh warming up for that
final today and tomorrow
uh well i'll probably watch the other
big finals that's gonna be on
today and then try and be fresh and
prepare
yeah do you have a favorite someone you
will root for in the final in the
champions league tonight
no not particularly all right we wish
you a great evening magnus enjoy
yourself and congratulations again